пане Михайло розкажіть З чим ви сьогодні
приїхали і куди в рідні міста Як то
кажуть вже 9 років
пройшло з 14-го року як от після Майдану
зразу з хлопцями на передову це тоді
перший і другий резервні батальйони
пізніше після загибелі Генерала
Кульчицького батальйону його імені і
якраз міста оці Краматорськ Слов'янськ
якраз рідні тому що перші бої перші
звільнення в 14-му році я отримав першу
07 тут поранення а вже 5.07 я вернувся
відмовився від від госпіталізації і вже
5.07 ми вже звільняли Славянск потім
Краматорськ і так дальше воно пішло і
вдавалося після цього депутатство І
кожен рік з якимись смаколиками з
якимись подарками сюда до хлопців на
передову на передній план
приходив новий рік ми з вифлеємським
вогнем з пластунами сюда приїжджали
тобто Все рідне все таке приємне після
22-го року після
повномасштабного вже як звільнили Київ
Ну до того обороняли Київ після цього
постійного сюда тобто немає різниці мій
підрозділ Я маю на увазі Кульчицький
пилка вони були тут Я був з ними то день
того тиждень побуду то 10 днів побуду з
ними В окопах там посиджу то щось
привезу маючи благодійний фонд бондара
Михайла боремось перемагаємо стараюся
забезпечувати хлопців автомобілями це не
означає що це я можливо тільки купляю
купляють всі хтось долучається сам за
кордоном наприклад що оплачує автомобіль
десь хтось збирає назберу і у різних
волонтерських організаціях і я через цей
благодійний фонд завозив вже більше 150
машин ми завезли на через благодійний
фонд це починаючи ще як під Києвом
реанімобілі потім джипи
броньовички грузові машини Ну мені з
Петром олексійовичем Порошенком тяжко
таскатися все-таки це потужність Але все
рівно 150 машин Я вважаю тоже не мало
Так це це також не мало І сьогодні
долучаючись також до збору коштів в
справа громад Я також приїхав сюди щоб
передати
і комплекси
мийні і Бані і автомобілі
тощо фонд Петра Порошенка привіз Якраз
для
95-ї для 25-ї бригади для 10-ї для 77-ї
Я також приїхав щоб подякувати хлопцям
разом з Петром олексійовичем За ту
роботу яку вони роблять І побажати нам
найшвидшої Перемоги і щоб вони живими і
здоровими поверталися додому
як у хлопців настрій
спілкуючись відчуває що бойовий бойовий
тому що
і Контрнаступ який планується
підсилюється все і головне усі подарки
які ти привозиш кожен раз піднімає їм
настрій просте навіть живе спілкування
розуміючи що приїжджають люди такого
рівня як Петро Олексійович сюда на
передову що вони відчувають що їх ніхто
не кидає що підтримка буде в подальшому
вони чують
які проблеми їхні Стараємося вирішувати
в парламенті тому дух бойовий хлопців
дух бойовий так змучені але змучені але
лице як то кажуть з Позитивом і все так
Що Я впевнений що буде швидко перемога
Ще цікаво що забути ви зараз в
парламенті відбуваються там Ну я так
розумію що виплати для військових
доводиться буквально вигризати Ну бачите
вдавши коли ми Нам вдалося притягнути
поправку яка повертає якраз
тих 30 тисяч військових мало того ця
поправка якраз і забирала високі
зарплати чиновників Тобто це фактично
разом з джерелом наповнення тих 30 000
тим більше ні на южаніна наша колега
кожен раз розказує її показує І де можна
в держбюджеті взяти ті кошти Тобто там і
фінансування отого каналу дурдом і так
дальше тому подібне тобто є дуже багато
джерел де можна взяти і повернути 30 000
нашим військовослужбовцям але видно
слуги народу мають іншу ціль їм легше
десь відправити на цей як то кажуть
канал на Марафон на ще щось і в такий
спосіб
наприклад відмивати гроші або навіть
умежити своїх політичних опонентів в
тому щоб вони там наприклад приймали
якусь активну участь там в телеефірах і
все тобто ми ж знаємо що і п'ятий і
прямий канал і Експресу там відключення
від цифрового тільки можна побачити їх в
YouTube каналі і все Тому баталії одні
нечесно зіграти розірбанити то Що
осталося ви бачите закупівлі які
не ну не показували до останнього тобто
я як як робиться ціноутворення не
показували Міноборони на як закупляє за
якими цінами і тільки от оцей резонанс
суспільний резонанс який і ми в тому
числі і кожен раз піднімали в Парла
менті зобов'язує їх зараз це все робити
тому я думаю що і вони будуть змушені
під нашим тиском от сьогодні наприклад
показували
рейтинг не рейтинги а статистику як який
політичні сили як ходять в парламент які
прогульники є хто європейська
Солідарність лідирує Тобто ми активно
ходимо туди і будемо ходити в парламент
і будемо доносити до людей свою позицію
а наша позиція одна зараз в пріоритеті
це збройні сили це Національна гвардія
це хлопці і дівчата які захищають нашу
Батьківщину Вони мають бути захищені і
соціально і
медично і і житлом і всім всім що треба
для цього для цього це ми будемо робити
як на тут на фронті як на передовій
привозячи її різні допомоги і смаколики
так і в парламенті відстоюючи їх
законодавчі